très litoria liste politique alexis
poulain bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors pourquoi ça prend
pas avec jean castex moins d'un français
sur deux lui fait confiance mais ça
prend pas parce qu'il ne suffit pas
d'avoir un accent une tête bonhomme et
puis et puis de voyager 1 de faire le
touriste dans son propre pays pour être
populaire on pourrait être proche des
français
le problème des manuels macron en
général de ce gouvernement en
particulier c'est que les technocrates
font confiance aux technocrates jean
castex est un énarque il a été
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
sous nicolas sarkozy
et il n'est pas politique au sens
politique du terme c'est à dire que il
est pas très bon pour la communication
on se rappelle de ce qu'il avait dit un
surstock qu'ovide que lui même ne
l'avait pas téléchargé qu'il n'en voyait
pas l'intérêt parce qu'il ne prenait pas
le métro ce genre de couac
quand on est premier ministre c'est
inacceptable c'est quelque chose que les
français entendent voix et dans un
gouvernement où la communication prime
parce que derrière vous avez des très
bons à la communication vous avez
quelqu'un comme marlène schiappa où
monsieur darmanin à l'intérieur le
président emmanuel macron qui fait tout
pour la comme lui n'est pas très bon en
communication et on voit la différence
finalement et derrière malheureusement
comme il n'est pas aidé par cette crise
du corps d'un virus et dire qu'on ne
voit pas les actions on a l'impression
que finalement il n'existe pas il n'a
prime pas et il ne trouve pas sa place
dans ce gouvernement de de l'image et
c'est surtout qu'il avait l'image de
monsieur déconfinement alors que
aujourd'hui on le voit la propagation du
virus est assez exponentielle 16000 son
cas ces dernières 24 heures on a une
moyenne de 17 mille et c'est en
progression constante cette dichotomie
entre l'avant et l'après
lui est né fasse également complètement
jean castex était comme vous le disiez
monsieur déconfinement sauf qu'il s'est
appuyé sur le cabinet bain and company 1
qui avait expliqué comment faire des
tests alors on a vu un le fiasco des
tests avant cela on avait le fiasco des
masques et puis on a eu ce déconfinement
de l'été où on a dit au français
finalement à les hisser les vacances
faites ce que vous voulez la rentrée se
passera à peu près bien on est on
on verra on gérera à vue mais un virus
comme celui ci ça ne se gère pas bu ça
se planifie alors on a fait le
commissariat au plan
avec monsieur bayrou mais ça ne suffit
pas et jean castex qui était responsable
des confinement est responsable de la
déconfiture actuelle c'est à dire que on
voit bien que ça ne marche pas
jean-michel bancaire qui devait gérer la
rentrée n'a rien géré du tout
aujourd'hui les principaux foyers de
contamination sont dans les écoles et
les facultés or aucune mesure
particulière n'a été prise ni en amont
ni maintenant qu'on voit que la crise
est à nos portes et on met encore une
fois le fardeau de cette crise sur les
français et sur les soignants alors oui
les français est bien dans les sondages
ont bien compris qu'il ne fallait pas
faire confiance à monsieur castex aux
autres et chute dans les sondages
jusqu'à 28% au moins de 30% parce que on
voit bien que personne ne gère et c'est
ça qui est grave il est premier ministre
donc on attend de lui des choix des
arbitrages et un gouvernement qui
fonctionne qui prend des choix qui lui
qui prend des des actions hors les
actions ne suivent pas et ça ça se voit
malgré les déplacements à répétition de
jean castex mais qui les prend justement
ces décisions sur les actions alexis
poulain on sait que jean castex à un
directeur de cabinet qui lui a été
imposée par l'elysée
c'est plus comme avec edouard philippe
finalement jean castex elle n'a t-il pas
les mains liées
mais complètement et c'est bien tout le
problème de ce gouvernement qui n'est
qu'un gouvernement d'acteur tout se
passe à l'elysée dans la tête des
malades macron avec alexis colère qui a
deux ou trois décident à peu près de
tout cette mise en scène finalement
arrive à sa fin parce que ce n'est pas
possible
a man il faut faire confiance aux autres
il faut travailler en équipe regardez
c'est la même chose pour eric
dupond-moretti il n'a pas pu choisir ses
collaborateurs au sein de son ministère
est partout c'est la même chose donc on
ne peut pas continuer comme ça c'est à
dire que la politique de l'homme sol de
la toute-puissance napoléonienne ça ne
marche pas au 21e siècle avec une crise
de l'ampleur du coronavirus il faut
faire confiance aux équipes
il faut libérer les énergies c'est
pourtant le message que voudrait faire
passer modèle macron mais non il est
dans le contrôle total et on voit bien
que jean castex est simplement là pour
s'effacer derrière la toute puissance du
roi parce que dès qu'une annonce
importante à faire le séparatisme et
bien cette entre mâcon qui va prendre la
parole
dès qu'une
loi importante va être mise en place
c'est encore le président qui va se
mettre en avant
donc jean castex n'est là que pour une
chose prendre des coups et se taire
alors il le fait très bien sauf que les
français n'aiment pas ça on aimerait
aussi un premier ministre qui lui aussi
travaille s'oppose au président parfois
quand c'est nécessaire et organise la
réponse à la crise du grenat virus qui
s'oppose au président c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi qu'edouard philippe a été
écartée on est à quelques mois
maintenant de l'élection présidentielle
il va falloir que ça dure comme ça sans
faire de vagues jusqu'à 2022 c'est la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron alors si
c'est la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
elle est perdante parce que derrière ce
premier ministre inexistant c'est lui au
final qui prendra finalement les coûts
parce qu'on va bien comprendre où est la
responsabilité ou l organisation ou la d
re la désorganisation du moins c'est
donc avoir un ministre qui agit c'est
aussi montrer que le gouvernement est
bien et est organisé et peut faire des
choses là on a l'impression d'une
incapacité totale et de gouvernement et
de l'exécutif avec en plus une assemblée
nationale où là les troupes dans marche
sont en train de se déliter
littéralement c'est à dire que vous avez
une fronde interne qui ne dit pas son
nom des gens qui ont déjà créé leur
groupe qui sont partis donc la majorité
est très faible et est le gouvernement
est lui aussi très faibles et tout ira
sur les épaules des baleines mâcon qui
semble bien faible et bien seul aussi à
l'elysée
l'autre handicap de jean castex et
d'avoir eu un un prédécesseur finalement
qui est parti avec une cote de
popularité plutôt hot
oui alors la cote de popularité c'est
une chose edouard philippe a
effectivement organisé le premier
confinement puis est parti en disant que
les choses étaient faites
s'il était premier ministre aujourd'hui
ils prendraient tous les crimes toutes
les critiques que prend jean castex
également donc il a su s'effacer et
partir au bon moment sachant qu'il avait
un point de chute à la mairie du havre
il est aussi je pense mis de côté 1 par
emmanuel macron je ne pense pas que les
deux hommes soient fâchés pour dire et
bien en 2022 si mma qu'on n'était pas en
capacité de se présenter parce qu'on ne
sait pas dans quel état sera le pays
d'ici deux ans et bien edouard philippe
et mis à l'abri un peu mieux au
congélateur en attendant on le sortira
tel hibernatus en disant voulez nier
bien et bien le voici tel que vous
rappeliez de lui il est capable
peut-être de répondre à vos attentes en
donc c'est un peu un joker c'est
quelqu'un qui attend son tour
et c'est pour ça qu'il a été je pense
mis de côté au bon moment parce
qu'aujourd'hui jean castex a le plus
difficile à faire c'est à dire gérer
cette crise relancer une économie
moribonde et puis et puis on ne sait pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'incertitude
qui prime et certainement pas la
planification merci beaucoup alexis
poulain d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur arte france ce soir